The left side of our equation looks good now. This is exactly the sort of thing
that we're looking for, y minus the constant. The right side is not quite there
yet though. Eventually, we want this to be x minus some constant and that whole
thing squared. Well, if you think about it, we're actually well on our way. If
you think about this right side in the general form of this equation, we can
multiply out the quantity x minus h squared to get x squared minus 2hx plus h
squared. You've seen things like this a lot of times before. So here, it looks
like we have this term covered, the x squared term, and we also have the term
the x to the first covered. What we're missing is this constant. What constant
do we need to add on to the end of x squared minus 8x in order to be able to
factor it in the form x minus h squared. So, just think of what constant belongs
here in order to make this expression on the right-hand side, the perfect square
of some polynomial of two terms.